[Music]
joyous scenes like this have been all
too rare in afghanistan recently after
two and a half weeks of competition it
was the spingar tigers who came out on
top in the spagiza cricket league
the tournament was scrapped last year in
the wake of the u.s withdrawal from the
country but while women's cricket
remains suspended the taliban has
allowed the men's game to start up again
qriket is happiness here most afghans
who face lots of challenges still come
to motivate the players
back in july midway through the
tournament there was an explosion during
one of the games in kabul injuring four
spectators
the game was able to be completed but it
was a stark reminder of the dangers that
afghans face on a daily basis
i want to tell those who oppose this
tournament that you can't break afghans
we are all one and when those people see
this crowd it's a big slap to their face
and show the unity of all afghans
over the past two decades sports
particularly cricket have been the rare
consistently positive stories to come
out of afghanistan
the men's national team set to tour
island this month both several players
considered among the world's best
cricket is the only game in afghanistan
where we're ranked in the world's top 10
and some of our all-rounders and bowlers
are in the top three in the individual
rankings we've achieved all of this
pretty quickly in around 20 years
economic sanctions have led to a
humanitarian crisis in afghanistan which
the international rescue committee has
warned could lead to more deaths than 20
years of war
despite this thousands of people turned
out to watch 32 games of cricket a game
loved by many and bringing much needed
hope during uncertain times
david stokes al jazeera